think this is a part of just being in a
[ __ ] up business that we're in yeah
and the kind of people that we
are you know i there is a layer of sense
of
sensitivity that i have right so it's
like you know i'm trying to take
certain things personally but there are
certain things like
you know a couple of months ago they
announced we're doing an all asian heist
movie
on right on um
amazon i don't know where it was right
and it had all these big asian names in
it
right and in my head i'm like i'm
reading the article about it and going
oh i won't be invited you know what i
mean i won't even have the opportunity
you know because there are certain thing
movements especially when it comes to
agents that i feel like that i should be
considered at least i'm maybe i'm doing
being too cocky
right but but it passes me by
even though i've i've done things like
so i called my agent so what's going on
with crazy rich asians
can you get me in you know i mean and
they're like yeah they're not
and i you can't just get me in i'll read
whatever
yeah they're not even you know what i
mean and then you go
oh there's another train passing me by
you know and it's like at some point you
know
you get it's hard not to get take it
personally yeah
right do you get that way no
why because of the houses no
no bob because i don't yeah because why
would you let that
[ __ ] up your path in your journey
because because i believe that
the show that you and i have right is
another train
right that it doesn't make any sense
that train isn't on your track bro
where's the train you're riding your
train you're i'm on the train
man i'm being very honest with you man
that's like saying
that's like saying when i saw kevin hart
sell out an arena
and i'm mad no that's different well why
why don't i spill out
that's completely different no it's not
completely different because that's the
same thing
because i could clearly go i could go i
could have went wait
why am i selling arenas why can't i sell
out arenas
that's not fair only no man you you're
in your lane and you're in your path
what did kevin do to get that make that
happen and then you just stay there you
stay in that lane and make that [ __ ]
happen
that's a good point you've
doesn't mean that that's it what you
want is your desire's there you told
that
you told the universe what you want yeah
it's gonna happen
just stay right here bro because when
you keep looking at the whole trick
i'm just saying bob he has to write a a
self-help book
you got to write fine bob i'm trying to
be funny what i'm trying to say is when
you're in this lane right here
okay and this is bobby's lane and if
you're too busy concentrating on these
trains passing you down
by passing you by oh i should have been
that movie i should have been in that
movie you stay right here watching them
instead of staying right here focused
and moving forward
because whatever it is you want is in
front of you but if you're going to sit
back and be in the trash you're going to
be in the fan seats like this and watch
the horse race run
you're never going to win bro
get the [ __ ] out of here
that's why he came here that's why he
came here i don't i don't know that was
i don't you're right dude you just don't
you just i think in many ways just now
right you changed my life
i think you put me back on the train
maybe
no i'm not no i'm now i know i'm
i was always gilbert don't make me that
don't give me that face
i'm trying to visualize what your train
looks like it can all my train's like
this
yeah you're training neon bro you know
what like i said when i when i sat here
you're ahead of your time
you're a neon bullet trainer you really
are ahead of your time
you've when i said you've always been
this guy
that that wasn't a dis that's really you
you've always been this guy you've
always been bobby lee
the world's not ready for you yet and so
the [ __ ] what
when it catches up it's gonna be huge
bro it already is
i'll suck your dick
i mean this every time when i leave here
bro come on my mouth you can come with
my mouth
i won't swallow i will not you know i've
been holding back a lot during that i
want to see
what i mean i wonder what your [ __ ]
tastes like
i probably yeah ponzu sauce yeah yeah a
little bit of ponzu i love
zoo i love ponzo a tad of chlorine
because that's what
it all smells like you know yeah the
third